so willkommen zum nächsten
tagesordnungspunkt
da geht es unter anderem um die
einrichtungs bezogenen pflicht das thema
hat und damit nachmittags schon mal und
ohne den genesenen status zwei anträge
der cdu csu fraktion liegen dazu
versuchen erleichterungen es gab ja eine
kontroverse und etwas wirbel um die
plötzliche verkürzung des corona
genießenden status werden sie sich
erinnern eine entscheidung des robert
koch institutes im januar das institut
hatte damals ja ohne vorherige
ankündigung über das was die dauer des
gegebenen status von sechs auf drei
monate verkürzt viele betroffenen
fühlten sich überrumpelt die
entscheidung des lka hatte auch
auswirkungen etwa beim zugang zur
gastronomie und veranstaltungen jetzt
hat
bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach schon mitgeteilt dass er
diese befugnis nämlich die festsetzung
des gemässigten system erkennt ihn so
die cdu csu fraktion hatte ich jetzt so
anträge vorgelegt und realisation wird
als erster
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen am 15 märz
diesen jahres soll die einrichtungs
bezogene impfpflicht in kraft treten und
nach wie vor sind zentrale fragen zu
ihrer umsetzung unklar wir fordern
deshalb heute mit unserem antrag die
bundesregierung auf endlich die
einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht solide
vorzubereiten
am zehnten dezember wurde sie hier
bundestag beschlossen und schon damals
war klar dass die umsetzung gründlich
von der bundesregierung vorbereitet
werden muss
einrichtungen praxen gesundheitsämter
arbeitnehmer und arbeitgeber nicht
zuletzt aber auch die bundesländer
warten seitdem auf klare
handlungsanweisungen aus dem
bundesgesundheitsministerium
es geht nach wie vor um die fragen eines
bundeseinheitlichen bundesweit möglichst
einheitlichen vollzuges
versorgungsengpässe in der pflege müssen
vermieden werden und eine vielzahl an
arbeits und sozialrechtlichen fragen für
die betroffenen arbeitnehmer und
arbeitgeber sind nach wie vor ungeklärt
vollkommen ungeklärt ist auch wie die
gesundheitsämter vor ort eigentlich ihr
ermessen ausüben sollen wenn zum
beispiel
versorgungsengpässe entstehen können
mittlerweile gibt es ein
informationsblatt des ministeriums das
23 seiten mit fragen und antworten
umfasst aber genau die zentralen fragen
bis heute nicht beantwortet
am sonntag konnten wir bei anne will
vernehmen sie einen pflegedienstleiterin
ganz klare praktische fragen an den
bundesgesundheitsminister gerichtet hat
zur antwort gab es keine dort aber
stattdessen den hinweis er könne statt
23 auf 40 seiten vorlegen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
es geht nicht um die masse der
vorzulegenden seiten sondern um die
klasse der antworten und hier ansehen
und ich will ihnen die diese situation
eins sagen es kann nicht sein dass die
umsetzung auf dem last zu lasten und auf
dem rücken von gesundheitsämtern
arbeitgebern arbeitnehmern oder gar
betroffenen ausgetragen wird das
zerstört auch das vertrauen in die
pandemie bekämpfung und in die politik
und beim genießen status zeichnet sich
ein ähnlich desaströses bild die
bundesregierung muss auch hier endlich
für ein klares vorgehen für eine klare
kommunikation sorgen die bürger müssen
müssen wissen woran sie sind man kann
doch nicht einfach versäumnis aus rk
abschieben und hier lothar wieler zum
sündenbock machen die verkürzung des
genesenen status von sechs auf drei
monate ohne rücksprache mit den ländern
und ohne ankündigung hat viele
verunsichert in dieser woche haben sie
jetzt eine halbe rolle rückwärts gemacht
geimpfte die haben jetzt in den nächsten
status verlängert bekommen ungeimpfte
nicht die nächste verwirrung die nächste
verunsicherung die nächste unklarheit
und deshalb vor den der sie auch mit
ihrem zweiten mit unserem zweiten antrag
auf auch hier endlich für klare
verhältnisse zu sorgen
die menschen haben ein recht auf
planungssicherheit auch in der pandemie
und ein solcher zickzackkurs zerstört
vertrauen in die pandemie bewältigung
vielen dank
vielen dank kollegen lindholz hat die
debatte eröffnet zwei anträge der
unionsfraktion liegen dazu vor also eine
zum genießen den status einer zu
einrichtungs bezogenen impfpflicht wie
gesagt die einrichtung pflicht das hat
mir ja gerade schon mal vor einer stunde
diese debatte da sind eigentlich viele
argumente auch schon ausgetauscht zum
genesen den status jetzt mal interessant
zu hören auf die spd zu sagen hatten
heike behrens gab es gestern auch eine
verständigung zwischen bund und ländern
heike behrens für die sozialdemokraten
die gesundheitspolitische sprecherin
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
was für ein schauspiel
inszenieren sie hier eigentlich liebe
kollegen von der cdu csu fraktion
planungssicherheit und solides handeln
fordern sie in ihren beiden anträgen von
der regierung und das elektrisiert mich
geradezu das will ich ihnen sagen denn
planungssicherheit und solides handeln
ist es was der cdu csu
ministerpräsident söder ein ums andere
mal sabotiert
mal durch sein vorpreschen mal durch
steile ankündigung und immer wieder
durch bayerische extravaganzen im
verlauf der pandemie uns als reichte das
noch nicht
und als reichte das nicht schon für
unsolides krisen management hat er nun
auch noch eins drauf gesetzt und mit der
ganzen union im schlepptau geltendes
recht selbstherrlich infrage gestellt
mit einem medialen paukenschlag wurde
das von ihnen selbst geforderte und
beschlossene gesetz ausgebremst das ist
weder solide noch seriös und es schadet
der notwendigen umsetzung der
einrichtungs gezogen werden empfiehlt
[Applaus]
sie haben damit den einrichtungen
geradezu die planungssicherheit genommen
die diese eigentlich brauchen was sollen
eigentlich die krankenhaus- und
pflegeheim leitungen davon halten die
seit monaten mit ihren beschäftigten im
gespräch sind um sie von der
notwendigkeit einer impfung zu
überzeugen was sollen eigentlich die
viele pflegefachkräfte die
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter in
hauswirtschaft reinigungsdiensten oder
anderen arbeitsbereichen in
krankenhäusern pflegeheimen und
ambulanten diensten denken die sich
haben impfen lassen um menschen zu
schützen die besonders gefährdet sind
alles gar nicht so wichtig war gar nicht
so ernst gemeint es beschädigt das
ansehen unseres rechtsstaats wenn so mir
nichts dir nichts von einem
ministerpräsidenten erklärt wird er
wolle ein gesetz nicht umsetzen
und alle die neben auf diesem holzweg
gefolgt sind sie haben wir nicht nur die
planungssicherheit beschädigt und
unsolide gehandelt sie halten damit auch
den fortschritt bei der pandemie
bewältigung auf und das ist
unverantwortlich
das gesetz zur einrichtung bezogenen
impfpflicht dient zuallererst dem ziel
besonders verletzliche menschen zu
schützen es wurde im dezember von einer
breiten mehrheit hier im bundestag und
einstimmig man erinnere sich einstimmig
im bundesrat beschlossen und jetzt
stehen alle länder in der verantwortung
und auch ihre verwaltungsebenen in der
pflicht es auch umzusetzen und die
solide vorbereitung die sie mit ihrem
antrag einfordern die läuft seit monaten
die handreichung des
bundesgesundheitsministeriums wurde
schon mitte dezember veröffentlicht und
sie wurde seitdem schon dreimal
aktualisiert anhand der fragen anhand
der fragen die gestellt wurden und das
gesundheitsministerium und die
gesundheitsminister der länder sind in
engem austausch zu allen
umsetzungsfragen und auch die
arbeitsgemeinschaft der oberen
landesgesundheitsbehörden konkretisieren
die ausführungsbestimmungen für die
landkreise und die öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienste also kein grund für
panik
das sei auch hier erhöhen es gibt sehr
wohl bundesländer die bereits digitale
erfassung plattform erstellt haben um
einrichtungen und gesundheitsämter zu
unterstützen die handreichungen und
erlasse vorbereitet haben und die
umsetzung vor ort zu erleichtern und
rechtssicherheit zu gewährleisten und
dabei da mutet es einfach nur bezahlen
wenn der bayerische ministerpräsident
vor die kamera tritt und wie der
sprichwörtliche elefant im
porzellanladen
verkündet was kümmert mich was ich mal
gefordert und selbst beschlossen habe
die wirkung ist fatal und der
scherbenhaufen lässt sich auch nicht
mehr dadurch kitten dass das land bayern
nun doch zur verzögerten umsetzung
bereit ist dieser populistische
ausrutscher wird dem heute mit dem heute
vorliegenden antrag nicht geheilt nein
im gegenteil sie versuchen mit ihren
fragen an die falschen adressaten das
vertrauen in die umsetzung der
einrichtungs bezogenen impfpflicht
weiter zu beschädigen erlauben sie noch
eine zwischenfrage aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion jagd gern
sehr geehrte kolleginnen während ich
hätte nur eine kurze frage und zwar mit
wenn die einrichtungs bezogene
impfpflicht kommt mit wie viel prozent
an pflegekräften rechnen sie die den
beruf verlassen werden
liebe frau zelda ich bin erst mal
erschüttert dass sie vorhin in der
vorigen debatte
gesprochen haben und dann gesagt haben
diese ampel koalition wurde das volk in
geiselhaft halten das muss ich sagen hat
mich tief erschüttert weil ich bisher
angenommen habe dass sie zu den
sachorientierten
gesundheitspolitikerin der cdu csu
fraktion
wir wissen aus anderen ländern die
bereits eine einrichtung bezogen im
pflicht eingeführt haben dass das was
vorher gesagt wurde bezüglich des
verlassens dieser berufe so nicht
eingetreten ist wir wissen auch dass es
zum professionellen selbstverständnis
von beschäftigten in diesen
arbeitsfeldern gehört dass sie alles tun
um dem hygiene schutz aber vor allem
auch den infektionsschutz zu dienen und
alles zu tun um menschen davor zu
bewahren dass sie an dieser stelle
geschädigt werden das ist etwas das
gehört zum selbstverständnis dieser
einrichtungen und das sollten wir
das war jetzt die beantwortung der frage
und jetzt haben sie noch
weil
sie haben ja vorhin auch zu dem thema
allgemeine endlich stellung genommen und
es sind gerade die großen pflegeverbände
von diakonie und caritas und auch andere
pflegeeinrichtungen durch die uns
dringend auffordern das thema
einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht
einzubetten in eine allgemeine
impfpflicht und dafür sollten alle denen
das wohl dieses landes am herzen liegen
sich einsetzen
ich komme
präsidentin wir übernehmen verantwortung
die als ampelkoalition aber ich sage
nochmal wir übernehmen verantwortung das
steht bei der cdu csu auf jeder homepage
und diesen staatstragenden anspruch dem
werden sie zur zeit nicht gerecht
allerdings war das für die
sozialdemokraten und wenn der bundestag
in dieser woche darüber debattiert haben
die gesundheitsministerin und minister
der länder indes längst angefangen die
eine impfpflicht sind um sie umzusetzen
und zwar gab es gab jetzt an einen
beschluss der
gesundheitsministerkonferenz
[Applaus]
sich auf arbeiten ebene
abgestimmt und sieht eine gute basis für
eine zügige und rechtliche hochgesetzt
anderen fraktionen die änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes zur
einrichtungs bezogen im fisch
beschlossen und jetzt wird die cdu und
csu dieses längst beschlossene gesetz
auf einmal solide vorbereiten lassen
haben sie den gesetzentwurf damals nicht
gelesen sondern blind den arm gehoben
statt die eine stimmbezirke endlich noch
heute vollständig und ersatzlos
abzuschaffen will man nun die arbeits
und sozialrechtlichen folgen für die
beschäftigten und die betriebe klären
man fordert die regierungen auf
gesetzliche rahmenbedingungen zu
schaffen welche den einrichtungen und
krankenhäusern am wirklichen umkämpfte
mitarbeiter nach belieben zu stellen und
zu entlassen hauptsache an der
einrichtung steht genügend elftes
personal zur verfügung
sobald jedoch die versorgungssicherheit
patienten gefährdet ist können plötzlich
und gf der ärzte krankenschwestern
pflegekräfte eingesetzt werden ihre
arbeitskraft wird weiterhin zur
verfügung stehen ist das ihr ernst
erkennt das virus personalmangel dieser
antrag ist an zynismus kaum zu
überbieten
sie beschäftigt wie sich aus
persönlichen gründen entschieden haben
sich nicht impfen zu lassen oder auch
die die nun auf einen booster impfung
verzichten wollen sind praktisch ab
diesem zeitpunkt in markanten
beschäftigungsverhältnissen das ist
untragbar und unsozial
deshalb gehört aber graf 20a des
infektionsschutzgesetzes umgehend
abgeschafft
alle zurzeit eigentlich längst gegen 19
kennen wir bei einer ansteckung des
geimpften ausschließen noch die
weitergabe der krankheitserreger an
dritte verhindern im gesundheitswesen
hat das zur folge dass der patient durch
die impfung des passes kaum geschützt
werden kann
das heißt
grundrechts einschränkung für das
personal trotz nicht existenten schützen
dazu kommen immer wieder häufiger
auftretenden erzeugung
die von kanzler stolz und den
altparteien in deutschland regiert
werden mit einer impfpflicht
einrichtungs bezogen oder allgemein
werden türen profi zwangsbehandlung
geöffnet wenn aus den letzten hemmungen
gefallen sind und die roten linien
überschritten gibt es kein halten mehr
vor weiterer und grenzüberschreitungen
deshalb legen wir denen wir als fdp
fraktion diesen antrag ab
die heraufsetzung des genesenen studios
auf 90 starker bauch und anfang an
rechtswidrig das hat das berliner
verwaltungsgericht bereits in zwei
fällen entschieden der bundestag heute
jedoch den sechs monate gewesen des
stadions nur vor sich selbst exklusiv
sichern was durch den lauten protest ofd
inzwischen wieder rückgängig gemacht
wurde meine damen und herren wie sie
sehen die afg wirkt
die politik hat durch dieses verhalten
die ständigen kurswechsel in der band i
bekämpfen das vertrauen der bürger
vollkommen verloren letztlich geht es
nicht um korrekturen sondern nur um die
völlige abschaffung aller maßnahmen
danke
und es folgt eine weitere erste rede im
deutschen bundestag nämlich von linda
heitmann bündnis 90 die grünen
vielen dank sehr geehrte frau
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen liebe
abgeordnete der union wir diskutieren
hier heute in 40 minuten zwei anträge
von ihnen die aber eigentlich drei
themen umfassen es geht um die
verkürzung des genesenen status es geht
um die umsetzung der institution
bezogenen impfpflicht und es geht ihnen
auch um die quarantäne regeln für
reisende mit kindern ich glaube wir sind
uns einig es wird diesen themen nicht
gerecht in 40 minuten alles zu
diskutieren
man könnte es auch zusammenfassen unter
wir diskutieren heute mal alles was der
union an der pandemie gerade nicht passt
sie
sie beklagen in bezug auf die verkürzung
des genesenen status dass dieser
innerhalb weniger tage von sechs auf
drei monate herabgesetzt wurde ja ich
gebe zu die kommunikation dazu war mehr
als unglücklich aber ich glaube wir
müssen einfach mal anerkennen dass in
dieser pandemie die wissenschaft in
einem unglaublichen tempo auch immer
wieder zu neuen erkenntnissen kommt und
dann ist es unsere aufgabe
auch als politik das mit einzubeziehen
das in unser politisches handeln und in
unsere politischen entscheidungen auch
mit aufzunehmen wenn wir die ist
wissenschaft wirklich ernst nehmen die
seriös daran arbeitet auch zu ergründen
wie lange eigentlich die wirksamkeit
einer genesung vorhält
sie fordern wir in bezug auf die
institution bezogene impfpflicht die
bundesregierung möchte dem bundesland
bayern dass diese institution bezogene
impfpflicht selbst im bundesrat mit
angenommen hat doch bitte einmal
erklären wie es die jetzt umzusetzen hat
meine damen und herren ich finde es
entbehrt nicht einer gewissen ironie
dass genau jene das bundesland das sonst
stets auf seiner sowie souveränität
pocht jetzt plötzlich wenn es die
möglichkeit hat das gesetz selbst vor
ort aus zu gestalten von der
bundesregierung gefordert alles
haarklein vorgegeben zu bekommen ich
finde dass es wirklich mehr als gut
ich möchte jetzt gerne in dieser alles
rund um corona debatte was uns so stört
zu der fragestellung kommen die mich
seit monaten umtreibt und das ist die
fragestellung wie bekommen wir es hin
dass wir endlich wieder in eine
situation kommen in diesem land in dem
die gesundheitsversorgung für alle
wirklich wieder gut gewährleistet werden
kann
mai
bis oktober letzten jahres war ich in
der suchtkrankenhilfe tätig ich hatte
mit verschiedensten einrichtungen der
suchtkrankenhilfe tagtäglich zu tun und
habe gesehen was die pandemie und was
dieser andauernde ausnahmezustand dort
eigentlich angerichtet hat gucken wir
uns das einmal an menschen die ein
suchtproblem haben
gehen in der regel als erstes zu einer
beratungsstelle dort können sie sich
normalerweise ganz unkompliziert und
kostenlos überall in deutschland beraten
lassen seitdem die pandemie angefangen
hat ist dies vielfach nur noch per video
möglich es gibt viel weniger termine und
ich glaube sehr viele menschen sind uns
in dieser pandemie an dieser stelle
wirklich verloren gegangen und weil sie
mit der technik nicht zurecht kommen
weil sie diese anlaufstelle dann nicht
mehr haben es geht weiter in der
suchtkrankenhilfe mit einem
qualifizierten entzug viele stationen
für einen qualifizierten entzug haben zu
beginn der pandemie geschlossen oder sie
haben die betten stark zurückgefahren
und auch die leistungen stark reduziert
ein qualifizierter in zug in der
suchtkrankenhilfe ist seit der pandemie
nur noch sehr bedingt möglich und auch
wenn wir uns die reha danach angucken
dann wurden hier viele plätze reduziert
weil die menschen alle in einzelzimmern
untergebracht werden müssen es gibt
viele sonderregelungen und auch hier
kann eine normale behandlung und reha
nicht mehr stattfinden zuletzt möchte
ich den blick dann auch noch auf die
sucht selbsthilfe lenken genau das was
viele menschen in der sucht immer wieder
am leben hält und ihnen einen normalen
alltag ermöglicht hier sind viele
persönliche begegnungen in den letzten
zwei jahren weggefallen wir haben davon
gehört dass zahlreiche menschen die seit
jahren trocken waren aufgrund dieser
diesem wegfall von persönlichen
begegnungen rückfällig geworden sind was
möchte ich mit diesem schlaglicht auf
die suchthilfe verdeutlichen ich möchte
ihnen verdeutlichen dass wir hier
wirklich mal den fokus darauf legen
sollten dass die behandlung auf allen
ebenen und unserem gesundheitssystem
seit fast zwei jahren dauerhaft
eingeschränkt ist und ich möchte
wirklich dafür plädieren dass wir hier
als parlament gemeinsam und konstruktiv
darüber diskutieren wie wir rauskommen
aus diesem dauerzustand das aus der
ausnahme und dazu lade ich sie ein
beispielsweise in der nächsten
sitzungswoche hier mit uns zu
debattieren kann die impfpflicht ein weg
sein zurück zur normalität wenn ja wie
muss sie ausgestaltet sein ich würde
mich freuen wenn sie sich da konstruktiv
einbringen statt sich im kleinen kleinen
solcher anträge zu verlieren wie sie sie
hier heute vorgelegt haben können
sagte heitmann die fraktion wissen 90
die allgemeine impfpflicht soll dann im
jahr ob es hier im bundestag debattiert
werden als nächstes erhält das wort für
die fraktion die linke die abgeordnete
kathrin vogler
katrin zugleich sprecherin für
gesundheitspolitik
liebe frau präsidentin meine damen und
herren wir reden hier heute über zwei
anträge der unionsfraktion in denen
neben einigem richtige auch so viel
unsinn steht dass wir ihnen leider nicht
zustimmen könne recht haben sie
teilweise jedoch in der
situationsbeschreibung da ist zum
beispiel der bauarbeiter geimpft mit
johnson & johnson der eines januar
morgens feststellen muss dass sein
impfstatus von jetzt auf gleich nicht
mehr ausreicht um mit dem bus zur arbeit
zu fahren oder da ist die frau mit der
fortgeschrittenen muskelatrophie um ihre
unabhängigkeit für fürchtet weiß ich in
ihrem achtköpfigen assistenz team zwei
menschen befinden die sich partout nicht
impfen lassen wollen auf die sie aber
eigentlich nicht verzichten kann und das
sind zwei von vielen menschen die
bundesregierung mit den neuen chor ohne
regeln zur einrichtungs bezogenen
impfpflicht und zum immunitätsausschuss
vor riesige probleme gestellt hat und
deshalb ist es richtig dass die frage
wer als geimpft und genießen gilt wieder
politisch entschieden und entsprechend
gut vermittelt werden muss hier steht
die bundesregierung klar in der pflicht
aber meine damen und herren von der
union sie haben doch beiden regelungen
hier im haus und im bundesrat zugestimmt
und auch jeder ministerpräsidenten nahm
ja keine erkennbare linie sondern drehen
sich wie das fähnchen im wind also das
schafft doch auch noch mehr
verunsicherung bei den menschen der herr
wüst im interview zum beispiel
herrschaft ist auch innerhalb von fünf
tagen drei mal seine meinung zur
einrichtungs bezogenen impfpflicht zu
ändern dass die organisch das für skater
wirklich nicht
kolleginnen und kollegen impfung sind
das wichtigste mittel um aus dieser
pandemie raus zu kommen da sind wir uns
ja auf der seriösen seite dieses hauses
eigentlich alle einig aber ebenso
wichtig das will ich noch mal sagen ist
das vertrauen der bevölkerung
und da hat nicht nur die union sondern
auch leider die bundesregierung einen
gewissen nachholbedarf
[Applaus]
die anweisungen können wir jetzt nicht
geben
ja ich habe mich auch gefragt was das
jetzt wahr solidarität irgendwie unter
abgeordneten gut als dieses erhält das
wort für die fdp-fraktion die
abgeordnete christine aschenberg geben
und sie ist die gesundheit bag
sprecherin der fdp-fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ja wir beraten
heute zwei anträge der cdu csu fraktion
der eine befasst sich mit der
einrichtungs bezogenen impfpflicht der
andere mit dem genesenen status und ich
möchte gerne mit der einrichtungs
bezogenen impfpflicht beginnen und ich
möchte zuallererst etwas klarstellen was
mir diesen tagen besonders wichtig ist
und was sowohl in der heutigen debatte
die wir auch vorher geführt haben als
auch in der öffentlichkeit immer wieder
völlig falsch dargestellt wird die impf
nachweispflicht bezieht sich eben nicht
auf einzelne berufsgruppen alle damen
und herren es ist vielmehr wichtig dass
jeder jeder der eine entsprechende
einrichtung betritt und darin mit den
wohl begraben gruppen geimpft ist und
das sind natürlich nicht ausschließlich
die pflegekräfte die pflegefachkräfte
sondern eben auch die reinigungskraft
der koch oder der hausmeister warum ist
das so meine damen und herren im
mittelpunkt steht für uns immer der
schutz der wohlhabenden gruppen das ist
sinn und zweck dieses gesetzes
dieses gesetzes das die ampel
richtigerweise vorgelegt hat und denen
die union zugestimmt hat und der auch
der bundesrat zugestimmt hat meine damen
und herren denn eine hohe impfquote beim
personal in den gesundheitsberufen und
in berufen die pflegebedürftige und
menschen mit behinderung betreuen ist
wichtig besonders wichtig um das risiko
und die gefährdung dieser menschen zu
senken und das hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht auch genauso
bestätigt frau kollegin glauben sie eine
zwischenfrage vom abgeordneten hilse von
der afg fraktion ein meine damen und
herren wir erleben hier einen weiteren
verzweifelten versuch der union
irgendwie in der opposition fuß zu
fassen es ist doch aberwitzig um nicht
zu sagen absurd dass ausgerechnet die
union sich jetzt kritisch zur
einrichtung bezogenen impfpflicht
einlässt und an vorderster front
natürlich mal wieder markus söder bayern
hat laut stärk die einrichtungs bezogene
impfpflicht gefordert bayern hat der
einrichtungs beziehungen impfpflicht im
bundesrat zugestimmt und bayern möchte
jetzt die einrichtungs bezogene
impfpflicht nicht umsetzen finde den
fehler das passt doch alles vorne und
hinten nicht zusammen meine damen und
herren
und auch in richtung bayern es gibt doch
tatsächlich bundes die die hände nicht
in den schoß legen sowie bayern sondern
gespräche mit den kommunen führen mit
allen akteuren im austausch stehen und
auch für eine gute möglichst digitale
umsetzung sorgen so zum beispiel mein
bundesland schleswig-holstein und
genauso auch
nordrhein-westfalen es geht also sie
müssen nun mal richtig hinschauen meine
damen und herren
selbstverständlich
selbstverständlich ist es in
bundesländern mit einer hohen impfquote
in den gesundheitseinrichtungen
leichter die nachweispflicht umzusetzen
aber dafür werden den gesundheitsämtern
bei denen die eben niedrige impfquoten
haben ein ermessensspielraum eingeräumt
das haben wir ganz bewusst gemacht und
das ist auch gut so meine damen und
herren anstatt wie bayern eine
bundesweite aussetzung der
nachweispflicht zu verlangen sollte man
sich lieber um eine zeitnahe umsetzung
kümmern und um eine erhöhung der
impfbereitschaft das wäre die richtige
maßnahme
und deswegen ist es auch gut dass ab
nächster woche ausreichend nowaks
impfstoff für beschäftigte zunächst
prioritär im gesundheitswesen eingesetzt
wird und ich kann nur alle auffordern
die jetzt auf nowaks gewartet haben sich
jetzt zeitnah impfen zu lassen dass sich
die richtige maßnahme meine damen und
herren so
wirklich verstehe viele
so wie ich auch die sagen ich möchte
nicht dass meine angehörigen in einer
einrichtung betreut werden in der die
mehrzahl der mitarbeiter ungeimpft ist
lassen sie uns gemeinsam daran arbeiten
die wohngruppen würze wirklich zu
schützen jetzt geht mir leider die zeit
aus ich hätte noch viel zum genesenen
status sagen wollen aber die präsidentin
ist leider dagegen und deswegen können
wir das vielleicht wie wartezeit klären
kann herzlichen dank
wittenberg große sorge weise ich zurück
die regelzeit haben wir uns gemeinsam
gegeben und sie dürfen jetzt aber gleich
noch etwas antworten nämlich nach der
kunst kurzintervention vom abgeordneten
hilse bitteschön kasse für die afg
faktor
es wird von unten kollege das wird von
unten an gemacht das mikrofon
wer hat der frau aschenberg dugnus ich
verschaffe ihnen jetzt noch ein bisschen
mehr viel zeit
genau ich möchte jahren eigentlich nur
die frage
von meiner geschätzten kollegen also ich
schätze sie zumindest für ihre rede
diese vor hingehalten hat wiederholen
mit wie viel
personen aus diesem medizinischen
bereich rechnen sie die dann aufgrund
dessen dass sie am 16 dann nicht mehr
auf arbeit gehen dürfen weil sie sich
eben aus guten gründen die haben sich ja
darüber gedanken gemacht sich nicht
impfen lassen und ich sage ihnen mal ich
habe es gestern schon der staatssekretär
in einer staatssekretärin gesagt wieso
die verhältnisse bei uns in sachsen sind
bei mir im kreis sind 44 prozent des
pflegepersonals nicht in görlitz im
kreis görlitz sind es 49 prozent da
haben sie schon mal so irgendwie ein
ansatz wie viele personen denn das
gesundheitswesen dann verlassen werden
es gibt sogar rettungswachen wo die
rettungssanitäter weil sie nämlich jeden
tag mit den teilweise katastrophalen
nebenwirkungen zu tun haben 80 prozent
gibt es rettungswachen bei uns die nicht
geimpft sind und die machen das nicht
und die machen das nicht deswegen weil
sie irgendwie stuhr oder stumpfsinnig
sind sondern weil sie jeden tag mit den
teilweise katastrophalen nebenwirkung zu
tun haben also womit wie viele personen
rechnen sie dieses mal
die medizin ihren medizinischen beruf
niederlegen werden weil sie eine
impfpflicht für sie
geschlossen haben
wie du
[Musik]
nicht besser herr kollege
wir kennen doch alle hier doch alle
ichzeit kampagne
gestartet wurde wo angeblich
pflegekräfte ihren beruf niederlegen
sollten und das ganze ist der hinterlegt
mit einer handynummer 0160 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 kann man nachlesen in den zeitungen
das ausland und gerade frankreich hat
uns gezeigt ich rede von deutschland
nicht stimmt dass sie nicht über über
den tellerrand schauen das haben wir
schon häufig wahrgenommen aber wenn man
europäischen ackerland schaut dann sehen
der gast ankündigungen ein beruf
aufzugeben und die tatsächliche
umsetzung ein sehr kleiner teil dann
danach war also insofern sind wir sicher
dass nicht sehr viele dann ihren beruf
aufgeben weil pflege pflegende
fachkräfte pflegeberufe wissen was für
einen tollen job sie leisten haben auch
ein verständnis dafür dass sie die
wohlhabenden gruppen die menschen mit
behinderungen die älteren menschen
besonders schützen müssen und deswegen
bin ich sicher dass wir auch jetzt mit
nowaks einen erheblichen teil derjenigen
die jetzt noch nicht geimpft sind zum
impfen bewegen können und hören sie
bitte auf mit ihren komischen
darstellungen das lockt ihn doch sowieso
keiner mehr fehlen darf
das wort hat der kollege tino sorge für
die cdu/csu porto und eben dem
bundestagspräsidium gab es auch einen
wechsel wir haben gesehen und petra pau
die bundestags-vizepräsidentin
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
man könnte die ganze debatte zumindest
bei einigen redebeiträgen auf den nenner
bringen politisches kabarett und ich
sage ihnen auch warum weil ich das schon
ein bisschen befremdlich finde wenn sich
meine durchaus geschätzte kollegin der
spd hin stellt mit einer moralischen
hybris und all diejenigen die bedenken
haben einrichtungs bezogen impfpflicht
beispielsweise und diese bedenken auch
äußern hier so hinstellen als seien
diejenigen nicht an dem wohl und wehe
der zu fliegenden und der pfleger
interessiert und das glaube ich sollte
man sich nicht antun
aber ich möchte noch mal auf das thema
genesenen status eingehen also ich finde
es wirklich besorgniserregend wenn hier
so ein bisschen lapidar darüber
hinweggegangen wird dass man sagt ja
dumm gelaufen schwamm drüber ist
wahrheit also ich darf sie nur daran
erinnern wir sind ja hier zur prime time
also
ich guck gerade ja der minister ist
leider nicht da aber ich darf sie nur
daran erinnern dass quasi diese nacht
und nebel aktion nicht eine lappalie wir
reden hier über millionen von menschen
bei dem über nacht quasi der im status
der genesenen status einfach mal
geändert worden ist und deshalb haben
wir als union auch eine kleine anfrage
gestellt ich darf sie daran teilhaben
lassen auch an den antworten ich habe
sie mir extra hier nochmal ausdrucken
lassen
und da kann man wirklich nur sagen es
ist haarsträubend und ist an
dilettantismus eigentlich nicht mehr zu
überbieten was da offensichtlich
passiert ist also wir haben gefragt wie
es zu dieser regelung über nacht kam und
wie man vor allem auf die idee kommen
könne das in dieser form zu machen auf
einer homepage und da ist allen ernstes
die antwort dass die verkürzung des
genesenen status ja an leicht
zugänglicher stelle mit hohen
verbreitungsgrad veröffentlicht worden
sei und da frage ich sie liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der fraktion
glauben sie wirklich dass jeder jeden
morgen auf der homepage des rk ii bei
aller wertschätzung schaut um den
genießenden staates abzufragen also
nehmen sie es mir nicht übel
und es wird noch besser es wird es wird
doch viel besser also jetzt von der
realität in der sie offensichtlich leben
will ich jetzt gar nicht weiter sprechen
aber wir haben auch gefragt wann hat das
lka mit der änderung des status begonnen
ist ja schon ganz interessant bei der
minister kann sich offensichtlich nicht
daran erinnern wenn er sich nicht daran
erinnern kann dann finde ich lässt das
tief blicken oder er weiß nicht was in
seinem laden und seinem haus passiert
und hat das bmg ernsthafte antwortet auf
die frage wann mit der änderung des
status begonnen wurde ein konkretes
datum kann nicht benannt werden liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen das ist die
bankrotterklärung entweder weiß man
nicht was im haus passiert man will es
nicht wissen oder man hat überhaupt
keine ahnung und das ist erschreckend
wie die kolleginnen kollegen
und der gipfel des teletrust ismus das
will ich hier auch nochmal ganz klar
sagen ist dass man offensichtlich sich
überhaupt keine gedanken gemacht hat wie
viele menschen das betrifft also wir
wollten ja mal wissen bei dieser
überlegung den genießenden status in
dieser aktion zu ändern muss man sich
doch zumindest auch aufgrund der
eingriffstiefe gedanken machen wie viele
menschen das betrifft wir haben deshalb
gefragt wie viele menschen sind davon im
täglichen leben betroffen und er hat das
bmg geantwortet der bundesregierung
liegen dazu keine daten und erkenntnisse
vor liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und
da kann ich nur sagen heidewitzka wenn
das ministerium solche grundrechts
relevanten dinge auf der homepage eines
nachgeordneten instituts einer behörde
macht ohne zu wissen wie viele menschen
das im täglichen leben betrifft dann ist
das besorgniserregend liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
und deshalb und deshalb unsere bitte
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen lieber
herr staatssekretär richten sie das
bitte herrn lauterbach dem minister
ausschließen sie ihre wissenslücken
ändern sie die kommunikation stellen
sich neu auch dies ja vorgeschlagen und
auch zugesagt wurde und stellen sie vor
allen dingen den alten status genießen
den status 180 tage wieder her so wie
das in der ganzen union der hallensaison
bitte sehr sehr schnell herzlichen dank
liebe kollegen
kino sorge war dass für die cdu csu
fraktion gestern allerdings da haben ja
die spitzen von bund und ländern den
beschluss gefasst die entscheidung über
die dauer des genesenen status wieder
dem bundesgesundheitsministerium zu
überlassen und bei der entscheidung
sollen auch die länder mitreden dürfen
heißt es in dem beschlusspapier des
migros fraktion hat nun dr christus an
taxis das wohl
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin verehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen insbesondere
von der union planungssicherheit geben
gemeinsam europäisch handeln dauer des
chinesen status auf 180 tage anheben
sind zentrale forderungen eines ihrer
hier kurzfristig eingereichten anträge
darin beschreiben sie folgendes zu recht
ja die politik hat eine große
verantwortung in der korona pandemie und
ja unsere entscheidungen haben enorme
auswirkungen auf die bürgerinnen und
bürger es erstaunt mich aber dass gerade
sie in ihrem antrag planungssicherheit
stabilität und gemeinsames handeln ohne
alleingänge einfordern genau das hätten
sie ihrem parteifreund und bayerische
ministerpräsident ein paradebeispiel für
alleingänge bei zeitnah auch mal
mitteilen können
erstaunt hat mich aber viel mehr ihre
forderung den genesenen status nun
wieder auf 180 tage anheben zu wollen
wissen sie was sie in diesem
zusammenhang sehr erhellend war die
gestrige sitzung des
gesundheitsausschusses sie waren ja alle
dabei in dieser hat der präsident des
robert koch institutes professor wieder
die wissenschaftlichen hintergründe der
reduzierung des genießens status auf 90
tage eindrucksvoll erläutert laut
widersetzt die omikron variante neue
rahmenbedingungen ein neuer serotyp eine
immun escape variante die die antikörper
bindung sowie die schutzwirkung massiv
reduziert daher war ist und bleibt die
herabsetzung der dauer des genesenen
status aus medizinisch
wissenschaftlicher sich auch weiterhin
absolut geboten
kollege zu kollege gestatten sie einen
fragen oder einatmen diskussionen sorgen
frau präsidentin herzlichen dank zur
erinnerung nicht nur dass die
staatssekretären dittmann die verkürzung
des genießens status in der
plenardebatte am 13 januar von dieser
stelle aus klar kommuniziert hat sie
haben diese auch zugestimmt und die
wissenschaftliche fakten lage sogar
ausdrücklich gelobt etwas was sie nun in
ihrem hier vorliegenden antrag als ich
zitiere schweren politischen fehler
bezeichnet wenn das keine politik der
inszenierten empörung ist was dann
wehrte und nun
hinter uns liegen vier gemeinsame
regierungsjahre zwei davon in einer
beispiellosen krise trotz schwierigen
entscheidungen war die politische
grundkonsens unter uns demokratischen
fraktionen immer gegeben dieser konsens
den haben sie allerdings zugunsten einer
parteipolitischen instrumentalisierung
der pandemie vor kurzem aufgekündigt das
ist nicht nur bedauerlich das ist in
dieser situation auch im höchsten maße
verantwortungslos ihre hier kurzfristig
eingebrachten anträge folgen genau
dieser strategie und gleichen mit
verlaub immer mehr einem schlechten
schauspiel wie es meine kollegin eben
gerade auch genau erläutert hat beispiel
gefällig sie kritisieren die reduzierung
des chinesen status im europäischen
kontext als inkonsistent dabei ist ihre
argumentation
inkonsistent ging es ihnen wirklich um
einheitliche europäische regelungen so
müssten sie auch aspekte wie die
vereinheitlichung des im zertifikat oder
der pcr testungen ansprechen lediglich
den genesenen status zu thematisieren
ist nicht nur inkonsistent sondern auch
ein politisch durchschaubares manöver
nicht
nicht eine selektive vereinheitlichung
von regelungen der schutz des
menschlichen lebens und die sicherung
unserer kritischen infrastruktur und
nikon sollten unsere höchste priorität
darstellen deshalb begrüße ich
außerordentlich dass der bundesminister
sich auch auf europäischer ebene auch
weiterhin für die reduzierung des
gelesenen status einsetzen will es wird
sie daher nicht verwundern dass wir hier
ihren vorliegenden anträgen
selbstverständlich nicht entsprechend
ihren politischen zickzackkurs den sie
hier fahren werden wir nicht
unterstützen sei es in der frage der
einrichtungs bezogenen impfpflicht des
genesenen status oder wenn man jetzt
erklärt dass die allgemeine impfpflicht
gescheitert sei ihre politische
inszenierung sorgt für verunsicherung
und untergräbt das vertrauen in unseren
rechtsstaat
deshalb und ich komme zum schluss sei
ihnen einst ins stammbuch geschrieben in
der politik verhält es sich oft wie im
theater schlechte inszenierungen und ich
liebe diesen satz lehrern ein theater
manchmal schneller als so manch
feueralarm herzlichen dank wir waren
auch nicht
das ist die vorlage hierfür den letzten
1 jetzt haben wir noch eine kurze
pension wir haben rein ja vielen dank
frau präsidentin lieber kollege kein
platz ist ich will nur ein punkt hier
nicht so stehen lassen weil sie aus dem
ausschuss zitiert haben wir übrigens
schön gewesen wenn dem ausschuss der
bundesgesundheitsminister anwesend
gewesen wäre er was leider nicht und
weil sie ja so referiert haben und so
taten als sei die herabsetzung des
genesenen status im ausschuss von herrn
wieder entsprechend begründet wurden auf
meine frage hin warum eine
differenzierung zwischen den genießenden
status für ungeimpfte genießen und die
impfte genießen vorgenommen worden ist
zwischen drei und sechs monaten die
frage um die es hier aber geht in
unserem antrag bezieht sich ja darum
warum wir wieder die situation hier
haben quasi bmg gegen den rest europas
aller europäischen länder sagen sechs
monate wir sagen drei monate da kann man
sich wissenschaftlich darüber streiten
und wenn sie jetzt hier sagen bei
unserem antrag sie wird in dem nicht
zustimmen also die die ursprüngliche
regelung von sechs monaten wieder
herzustellen dann verstehe ich nicht
warum sich die ministerpräsidenten in
der mpk genau auf diese sechs monate
jetzt geeinigt haben also insofern
verstehe ich jetzt bin ich ehrlich
gesagt verunsichert wenn sie mir das
erklären könnten wäre ich ihnen sehr
sehr dankbar
möchten sie erwidern dann haben sie es
wird
ja sehr geehrte frau präsident erzeuge
ich will das gern nochmals
vervollständigen weil sie das eben
gerade nämlich angesprochen haben wegen
des gesundheitsausschusses ist ihre
frage war nämlich eine andere ihre frage
weil nämlich die ob denn das robert koch
institut seine bedingungen zu beginn der
woche nämlich nochmals geändert hätte
und dementsprechend an dem ich hier
wieder ein deutlich eindrücklich
erläutert dass das fake news gewesen
sind denn ihre kollegin verhindern auch
in einer rede dass auch nochmals
versucht zu bestätigen die beiden
artikel er war ziemlich verärgert die
frage der wissenschaftlichen die frage
der wissenschaftlichen begründbar
begründung der reduzierung des genesenen
status war eine frage der kollegen
behrens und dementsprechend wollte ich
das einfach nur zurechtrücken und ich
muss ihnen ganz offen sagen ihre
argumentation überzeugt mich nicht ihre
argumentation das sage ich ihnen auch
ganz offen die beiden anträge und ich
wiederhole das sehr gerne sind ein
schauspiel das hat frau behrens vorhin
auch richtig gesagt und ich wiederhole
es gerne auch mal noch einmal schlechte
inszeniert und schlechte inszenierung
lehrern wirklich manchmal ein theater
schneller als so mancher feueralarm
herzlichen dank
sogar wirklich die vorlage für den
letzten redner denn sie aus der
unionsfraktion kann darauf jetzt noch
mal reagieren stephan stracke wird es
sein
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren aus guten
gründen haben wir im dezember letzten
jahres die einrichtungs bezogene
impfpflicht beschlossen und den
beschluss damals stand ganz unter dem
eindruck der delta variante die
einrichtungs bezogen impfpflicht ist
richtig aber gut gemacht und gut gut
gemeint ist aber nicht gut gemacht und
es bedarf eines praxistauglichen
bundeseinheitlichen verzugs vollzugs und
sie haben sie liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
aus der links gelben koalition die
länder und die praktiker vor ort
vollkommen allein gelassen wie können
sie denn sonst erklären dass die
gesundheitsministerkonferenz
beschließt wir fordern auf unverzüglich
zitat alle offenen vollzugs fragen durch
vollzugshinweise einschließlich der
notwendigen abwägung kriterien
abzustimmen woher kommt denn das wenn
dann alles in ordnung ist so wie sie es
darstellen es bedarf eines
handwerklichen
ordnungsgemäße nördlichen umsetzung und
wenn das nicht erfolgt ihre kolleginnen
kollegen von der links gelben koalition
dann verliert der staat an
glaubwürdigkeit und in bayern darauf
hinweist dann ist es genau richtig weil
sie eben an dieser stelle nicht die
notwendigen handwerklichen fähigkeiten
haben dass tatsächlich gut aufzusetzen
und es bleiben tatsächlich eine vielzahl
an offenen arbeitsrechtlichen
fragestellungen was ist mit dem
vergütungsanspruch was mit den
freistellung und kündigungsmöglichkeiten
nachweise nicht vorgelegt werden wie
wird sichergestellt dass der arbeitgeber
auch tatsächlich informiert wird und die
antworten die sie hierzu bieten bleiben
vage unklar und letztendlich dürftig und
ihre handreichung das ist doch das
gegenteil von rechtssicherheit und das
gegenteil von klarheit in der praxis im
umgang mit diesem gesetz und deswegen
verwundert ist ja auch nicht dass die
länder hier in diesem bereich
tatsächlich so auftreten unter
demonstrieren und auf eine kernfrage
gibt das
bundesgesundheitsministerium überhaupt
keine antwort welche abwägungs kriterien
sollen denn die gesundheitsämter bei
ihrem ermessen spielraum den tatsächlich
sie leiten es gibt doch ein
spannungsverhältnis auf der einen seite
den besseren schutz für die patientinnen
und patienten und auf der anderen seite
die sicherstellung der flächendeckenden
versorgung den den betroffenen
einrichtung und dieses
spannungsverhältnis das müssen sie
auflösen das muss der
bundesgesundheitsminister auflösen die
praxis braucht antworten liefern sie
diese endlich sonst verursachen sie ein
pflege chaos mit der umsetzung dieses
gesetzes und das wollen wir nicht denn
uns sind die menschen nicht egal ihnen
offenbar schon liefern sie endlich geben
sie den auftrag an die bundesregierung
einen plug praxistauglichen vorzug
sicherzustellen wir geben ihnen heute
die gelegenheit damit stimmen sie
unseren anträgen zu
dem anschlag war dass jede zu redner die
unions-forderung hat zwei anträge
vorgelegt und wird damit keine mehrheit
finden zum teil auch diese weiter
beraten damit ist sie auch